Le livre voyageur : vous connaissez ?
Le principe consiste à laisser un livre
à l'endroit où on l'a terminé :
un café, un hôtel, une gare...
le livre est mis à la disposition d'un autre lecteur
qui fait la même chose et le livre voyage.
Ces deux dernières journées
étaient consacrées à cette pratique.
Alors, je sais ! En période de confinement
c'est pas la meilleure idée...
Mais ce principe peut être adapté aux trajets courts et même très courts : à l'intérieur d'une même famille.
C'est ce que je faisais quand mes
enfants étaient plus jeunes
et c'est ainsi, par exemple, que nous avons lu
"La gloire de mon père"
je lis deux pages à haute voix.
Mon fils récupère le livre, en lit une,
puis, le plus jeune 5 à 10 lignes.
Essayez, vous verrez c'est un vrai moment d'évasion,
une "capsule de déconfiné"...
Allez, à demain et n'oubliez pas,
il est encore un peu trop tôt pour tourner la page,
nous sommes tous confinés mais en reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors, pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...